There are currently over 14,000 animals on
the International Union for Conservation of
Nature’s Redlist of species that are facing
extinction.
So should we let nature take its course or
step in to save them?
I mean, species come and go over time.
Look at the dinosaurs!
Actually, you can’t, because they went extinct…
Studies suggest that species are going extinct
faster now than before, and we’re to blame.
We keep cutting down their forests, paving
over their land so they have nowhere to go,
not to mention introducing new predators and
diseases.
So maybe we should preserve them … out of
guilt?
Or maybe we should keep the incredible variety
of nature around!?
It’s a puzzle.
The Endangered Species Act of 1973 states
that threatened species are of “aesthetic,
ecological, educational, historical, recreational,
and scientific value to the Nation and its
people.”
But take away all the things we’re doing
to kill-off species, and all the things nature
is doing to weed them out, and it’s still
really hard to preserve some species.
Because animals need to mate to make more
animals, and helping them accomplish that
is harder than you’d think…
For one thing, we’ve got to get the animals
in the mood.
And that’s not always easy.
We don’t always know the social factors
they need to become aroused!
For example, in a managed space (like a zoo)
the zookeepers might clean up their enclosure,
inadvertently removing something that’s
a super turn-on -- like a pheromone signal.
We can look for physiological issues too,
like if they’re not mating because they’re
sick!
But, even if they’re healthy, and we’re
not messing with their environment, maybe
they still don’t mate!
And often we have no idea why.
So is it worth the effort?
That’s not for me to say — I’m an animal
lover so yes, save all the animals!
But there is another thing to consider…
money.
Captive breeding programs have been in existence
for about half a century.
And some have been really successful!
But regardless of outcome, the one sure result
of a breeding program is a lot of time and
energy is spent trying to keep species off
the endangered list.
The California condor reintroduction program
was one of the most expensive efforts ever,
costing a total of more than 35 million dollars
since 1987.
And giant pandas can cost upwards of 2 million
dollars a year for a zoo to host.
But there’s an upshot.
Having a rare species like pandas in a zoo
for breeding will attract visitors, particularly
if and when there’s a BABY to come see.
That’s revenue that can go a long way to
fixing their habitat and figuring out how
to get those pandas to mate.
On the other hand, some would argue that the
money spent on zoo enclosures and breeding
programs would be better spent preserving
natural habitats so the animals aren’t displaced
in the first place.
There might be a loss of revenue from visitors,
but nature preserves are still really fun
to visit even if you aren’t as likely to
see an exotic and interesting furry friend.
So there’s a lot to consider when we talk
about conserving species… but I still vote
for saving sweet little (and big) animals.
If you love science be sure to subscribe for
more Seeker.
Zookeepers sometimes have to go to lengths
to get animals to mate in captivity.
These pandas are watching porn.
Yep.
That's real science!
Watch it on Wild Sex -- here.
And it gets crazier.
Scientists have done in vitro fertilization
to pandas!
Thanks for watching.